So let's think about what we
did in that last video and
maybe do it in a little
bit more of a visual way.
So let's say this rectangle
that I'm about to draw is
the set of all the things
that I guess can happen.
It's a set of all
of the outcomes.
And we know from the get-go,
and we're still doing that same
example where I have a bag of
coins and one of them
only has heads on it.
Two sides are heads, the
other ones are normal.
So, if this is the whole set of
things we know that there's a
1/10 chance that we pick the
coin that only has heads.
So let me say out of
this area-- I don't
know-- this is 1/2.
That's 1/4.
So 1/10 is going to be
about that much, roughly.
So this area right here.
And let me color it.
Let me color it a color.
So that area right there, this
is the chances that we got
the two-sided sided coin.
And this whole area, this
is all a normal coin.
And then we said, oh, you know,
what are the chances that
we get 5 heads in a row?
Well, if we had a normal coin,
there was a 1 out of 32 chance
that we get 5 heads in a row.
So whatever this area
is, 1 out of 32.
So I'll do it in a column.
It's roughly there.
It can be a little messy.
And I'm assuming that this
column right here is 1/32
of this normal area.
So this is a situation of
normal-- I'll just write this
as n-- and that upside down
U means and in set theory.
Or it's a kind of intersection.
But it means and I got
5 out of 5 heads.
And if we think about,
what is the area of this?
Well, it's going to be
the area-- it's 1/32
of the normal area.
And the normal area is 9/10.
So this is equal to the
normal area, which is 9/10.
And then 1/32 of that.
Times 1/32.
Or you could also, another way
of viewing that area, you could
say that well, that area,
that's the probability-- I'll
do it in the same color.
That's the probability of
me getting-- I'll just
write 5 out of 5.
5 out of 5 means 5
out of 5 heads.
That's what probability of
getting 5 out of 5 heads
given that I picked
a normal coin out.
Times the probability that I
picked out a normal coin.
And so this is 1 out of 32,
and this is 9 out of 10.
And I'm assuming that the
area of this entire magenta
rectangle I already
drew, that's 1 or 100%.
Or however you want to view it.
And so this is 1 out of
32 times 9 out of 10.
So this is 9 out of 32.
So this whole thing, the area
this entire of this entire
magenta rectangle, is 1.
Then the area of this that I
just shaded in, this is 9/320.
Another way of viewing this,
this is also the probability--
this area right here is also
the probability that I got
5 out of 5 and that I
picked the normal coin.
So that's also equal to.
Both of those things
are true in this area.
In this area, if I have a point
in that area-- this might be a
little abstract for you-- if at
any point, it is true that I
got 5 out of 5, and I have
picked a normal coin.
So that's also going to be
equal to and I'm doing an
arbitrary color change here.
9 out of 320.
So we could say in general,
that the probability of me
getting 5 out of 5 coins, given
that I got a normal coin times
the probability that I got the
normal coin-- that is going
to be equal that 5 out of 5
happens and I got the normal.
That equals probability
of 5 out of 5, and I
got the normal coin.
Fair enough.
Let's go to the
other side of this.
This kind of yellowish
color here.
There's a probability I
got a two-sided coin.
And then given that, what's
the probability that
I get 5 out of 5?
Well, pretty much,
this entire area.
It's also true that
I get 5 out of 5.
So the probability that I get 5
out of 5 and two-sided, it's
equal to the probability--
oh sorry, and.
And two-sided, is equal to the
probability of 5 out of 5,
given the two-sided coin
times the probability
of the two-sided coin.
So this is 1, right?
If I got the two-sided coin I'm
definitely going to 5 out of 5,
That's why this whole
area is filled in.
And then, the probability of
the two-sided coin we know
already is 1 out of 10.
So this area is 1 out of 10.
And so what is the total area
where I have 5 out of 5?
Well, it's going to be
this area over here,
which I figured out.
Which was 9/320 of this
entire rectangle.
And then this whole area is
also another area where I
got 5 out of 5 because I
picked the two-sided coin.
And that's 1/10.
In the last video we would
essentially-- if we want to
know the chances of getting
5 out of 5, it's this
total rectangle.
I say this without showing
you anything, so let
me-- it'll be red.
And I think you get the point.
That is the 5 out of 5,
so it's going to be this
area plus this area.
And that is why it was 9 out
of 320 plus 1 out of 10.
And we had the
answer last time.
Fair enough.
So let me pose a slightly
more difficult problem.
I don't know if I should have
just erased that, but I did.
So let's move forward.
What is the probability that I
picked the two-sided coin given
that I got 5 out of 5 heads?
And remember, this is different
than the probability that I get
5 out of 5 heads given
the two-sided coin.
What's the difference?
This says I picked the
two-sided coin, now what's the
probability I got 5 out of 5?
Well that's equal to 1.
We're guaranteed to get a
million heads in a row.
But this says I put my hand in
the bag, I didn't look at which
coin I got, I just flipped it
five times and I know that
I got 5 heads in a row.
So now I say, well, what is the
probability without looking at
the coin, what is the
probability that this was
the two-sided coin
that I picked up?
Well, we can go back to
what we said before.
Let me just say it a
little bit abstract.
Before I clear this, we know
that the probability of a
given b, or the probability
of-- well, actually.
Let me start over.
The probability of a and b
happening, if you remember that
thing that before I erased it,
is a probability of a given
that b happened times the
probability that b happens.
If both of these things have to
happen then we could say, well,
definitely b has to happen.
And then, whatever the
probability of a happening
given that b happened.
This could be exclusive events.
If these are independent
this could be equal to the
probability of a times
the probability of b.
But we don't know for sure that
they're exclusive events.
So the probability of a given b
could be the probability of a.
It might not be dependent on b
at all, but we don't know that.
Let's ignore that.
So the probability of
a given b is that.
But we also know that the
probability of a given
b is equal to-- I mean,
the probability-- sorry.
We also know the probability of
a and b is also the same thing
as the probability of
b and a happening.
The same thing.
And so that's the probability
of b given that a happened,
times the probability
that a happened.
By the same logic.
Well, we see that this is
equal to this, so this
has to be equal to that.
So let's write that down.
And we're going to do a lot of
applications; I know this is
a little abstract right now.
So that tells us the
probability of a given b times
the probability of b, is equal
to the probability of b given
a, times the probability of a.
And then, let's just
divide both sides by a.
And we get this, the
probability of b given
a is equal to this,
probability of a given b.
Times the probability
of b divided by the
probability of a.
And this is called Bayes'
theorem or Bayes' law.
And this is what we will now
use to figure out the
probability that we got the
two-sided coin after seeing
that we rolled or we
got 5 heads in a row.
See you in the next video.